what you're about to see is a short work
in progress preview of Dead Island 2
Gameplay and just a glimpse of The Wider
epic pulp Adventure spanning the undead
Streets of LA
our journey starts in Bel Air just a few
hours after the introduction of the game
infected but somehow immune to the
zombie virus
our immediate goal is to reach the
authorities at the Halperin hotel and
Evac Center south of here in Beverly
Hills Vex centered this way
Cochran Hotel get my Suite ready between
our roster of six Slayers we've selected
Danny
a foul-mouthed brawler from Ireland with
a twisted sense of humor
she's a tenacious yet balanced character
well suited to an agile style of combat
oh
staying mobile and waiting for your
moment to strike will be key to survival
at this playstyle
stuff
hitting stuff solves everything
most of our Slayers have different
personalities stats and starting
abilities but thanks to our flexible
skill system you can personalize their
fighting style in any way you see fit
let's pause a second thanks to our
revolutionary dismemberment technology
called flesh crushing bones slicing
muscles and melting zombies will always
look bloody and feel spectacular this
realistic locational damage is not only
for show but will allow players to
strategically Target the individual
weaknesses of different deadly foes
thank you
despite the outbreak our world is alive
and kicking with Oddball survivors and
crazy side quests to complete are you
still out there
hey can you hear me
hello Don't Run Away we need to help
each other let's ignore this request for
now and continue towards the Halperin
Hotel I should check my map all these
streets look the same the road to
Beverly Hills is just beyond that
mansion
not one to pass up a shortcut
it's like we have enough Firepower but
we should be careful nonetheless
[Music]
yeah
sometimes it's best to choose when and
when not to engage
so let's try to find some shelter
if you feel the urge to fight though our
world is filled with tons of exciting
weapons each with their own unique and
brutal fighting style
for some satisfying dismemberment bladed
weapons are always King
and thanks to our flush system
cutting through zombies with your Katana
feels as smooth as slicing butter
foreign
for some tactical crowd control look no
further than strong heavy tools like a
sledgehammer
okay
what
weapons like this are perfect for
crushing bones and clearing a path
alongside a copious amount of melee
weapons guns offer a powerful addition
to Your Arsenal
capable of slaying long-range targets
and triggering deadly traps and
explosions
[Music]
be careful not to waste too many bullets
while you're having fun
okay back on track to get to this hotel
of theirs
smells like me Mars boils stew we found
the Evac checkpoint the road to Beverly
Hills is just up ahead
things are about to get a lot rougher so
we should upgrade our weapons and equip
ourselves for the challenges ahead with
workbenches scattered all over Los
Angeles players can retrofit their tools
with DIY mods and perks creating the
most obnoxiously crazy weapons from
flaming katanas to electrified daggers
and exploding hammers the possibilities
are endless and the outcome always
bloody
thank you
like most of the districts in La there
are multiple Pathways we can take to
reach our destination
with challenges to unlock characters to
meet and stashes to uncover
venturing off the beaten path has its
benefits
sounds like someone's having a party
let's check it out hello
[Music]
uh sorry zombie party's over I'm not a
zombie Pizza
do you have pizza of course I do now let
us in uh yeah well if I open this door a
whole load of zombies might rush in and
I'm pretty sure that's a bad thing then
why have you left the gate wide open oh
yeah well
we're having this big party right and
some of the guys not me were riding on a
gate and it broke now there's a whole
bunch of spares in the garage but it's
like full of Riff Raff fine I'll get
closing in A Lash
I'll hit the garage button you bouncing
party crashes and fix things up and then
dude Mikasa is is uh your casa hey Roxy
we got company find your jeans
we've agreed to fix the rockstars kick
time to go to work hell yeah yeah
fighting music I can jam to this
foreign
with dozens of deadly zombie types each
Undead archetype you encounter presents
a unique challenge with different
strengths and weaknesses to overcome
boys but I should close that gate now
[Applause]
you're a good breaker
this will work
[Music]
it's a better face this zombie horde we
expanded the equipment at the player's
disposal
curveballs are a brand new exciting
addition offering both lethal and
tactical advantages
take meat bait for example a nasty sack
of Blood and Guts that can draw zombies
away from you
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect for some gruesome distraction
s
genius hey
were you getting the pizza or will you
fighting zombies in the yard feeding
Pizza to the zombies
no pizza sorry man big evacuation party
you know oh [__] we gotta get to Evac
Roxy
Roxy hey
we should get back on track to the Evac
Center
from the iconic Hollywood Hills and
Venice Beach to the a-lister mansions in
Santa Monica and Bel Air neighborhoods
our story takes players on an epic
roller coaster ride through LA's most
iconic vibrant landmarks
the Halperin hotel is just down the
valley
occupied by the now Undead military and
ravaged by Massive earthquakes and
wildfires the hotel is now a powder keg
lucky for us though we've introduced a
powerful set of skill cards that enhance
Slayer abilities to help level the
playing field
what's more players can swap and combine
them tailoring their playstyle to suit
any scenario
Halpern Hotel
can check out any time you like
[Music]
[Applause]
quiet isn't it
um
we've decided to adjust Danny's Bill to
better resist Close Quarter attacks and
deal slow but powerful damage
[Music]
[__]
in Dead Island 2 your environment is
also another resource to exploit in your
quest for survival
from car batteries the gas canisters and
assets though chaining Elemental effects
like electricity fire and Caustic Acid
is just another way to wreak havoc on
the Dead
while locked at this stage in the game
by tapping into your corrupted DNA
you'll be able to unleash deadly
mutations and explosive abilities that
mimic the powers of the undead
we call this
Fury mode
with the military all but gone we need
to find another way to contact the
authorities
while Scavenging for resources we'll
have to face new and unexpected zombie
encounters
what's a little fire huh I'm sure I can
find something to put it out in Dead
Island 2 you'll face more than simple
walkers
these deadly and challenging mutations
pose unique threats
beyond the dozens of grotesque variants
in La Apex are hyper mutated zombies
that pose terrifying challenges with
unique powers and behaviors
and our standard zombies come in all
sorts of unexpected variants
with the fire extinguished our hotel
Excursion ends with Dany discovering a
functioning military radio breaker
breaker can anyone hear me
I hear you I'm Dr Reed unaware that
another Sinister and quite unique
encounter is waiting in the dark doctor
put me on hold for just a moment hey
wait I need you
our behind the scenes preview has come
to an end but with so much more to show
you in the coming months we hope you
enjoyed this small snippet of Dead
Island 2.
do you and La slayers
[Music]
right
[Applause]
[Music]